stärkstes highspeed netz der welt von
wegen die realität gerade auf dem land
in deutschland die hat leider relativ
wenig mit highspeed zu tun
frank thewes kind das will er daten
schnell versenden muss er diese auf
einen stick laden dann ins auto steigen
und damit 30 kilometer weit fahren zum
nächstgelegenen schnellen anschluss
richtig und dann muss er den stick
natürlich noch an eine brieftaube binden
und die fliegt damit dann in die cloud
meine damen es ist echt so erbärmlich
immer nur vor wahlen über
digitalisierung reden hilft auch nicht
wenn man das ernst meint kostet das eben
richtig geld
leider hat unsere regierung das thema
glasfaser aber überwiegend der telekom
überlassen und für die rechnet sich das
hat nicht das zeug bis ins letzte kraft
zu verlegen hier ganz neue werbung
stress hektik leistungsdruck das muss
nicht sein
entschleunigen sie doch mal mit unserem
super langsamen deutschen internet
e-mail anderen braucht sieben stunden
zum hochladen
kein problem einfach nochmal die
kompletten buddenbrooks lesen
mit den sturm sind die fenster die türen
ständig zu begleiten und wer braucht
schon netflix wenn er sich endlich mal
wieder ausführlich mit seiner frau
unterhalten
auch die sprache ja und da war das
lohnen du hast die zeit der
privatisierung war eine super idee ganz
toll
vielen dank an alle die das ein schöner
dabei wäre schnelles internet heutzutage
noch fast genauso wichtig wie strom oder
wasserversorgung warum verbuddelt der
staat nicht endlich selber im großen
stil die leitung manche andere ärmere
länder kriegen das doch auch gebacken
dieser satz der kanzlerin sagt
eigentlich alles
wir wollen dass das internet eine
verheißung
ja denn vorfreude ist die schönste
freude
ja klar du man ist ja doch meistens auch
enttäuscht wenn sie im internet dann
kommt man praxis aus und denkt na ja wer
kann uns da jetzt noch helfen
hier haben wir nicht nur diesen einen
digital kommissar in brüssel was sagt er
denn nun erste früchte kompetent fonds
ist konnte bevor sein kulturen in
creating and developing your baby super
info ich frage zurück
[Applaus]